Und morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Sag mal, ich hätte dich neulich mal dringend erreichen müssen. Kannst du mir von dir mal eine Krisennummer geben?
Tim, ähm verstehe bitte, dass ich darauf keine Antwort geben möchte. Warum? Ein Teil dieser Antwort würde dich verunsichern.
Logbuch Netzpolitik, äh die einhundertsechzigste Ausgabe direkt aus dem,
verunsicherten Land oder vielleicht auch nicht, wir wissen's nicht so ganz genau, die äh Aussagen sind sehr unklar, ist alles sehr ambivalent.
Aus äh gehen sie bitte weiter. Hier gibt es nichts zu sehen. Hier kommen wird äh gehen sie bitte weiter, das würde sie nur verunsichern.
Ja, was ein.
Ja, da fällt einem fast gar nichts mehr dazu ein, aber äh ich habe so das Gefühl, wir müssen doch ein bisschen was dazu sagen. Oh, es ist einfach ähm,
Keine, kein, kein keine Woche gewesen, die jetzt irgendwie unserem Wunsch nach äh weniger schlechten Nachrichten in irgendeiner Form äh zuträglich gewesen wäre,
Nee. Äh eigentlich läuft alles wie äh immer. So.
Und jetzt halt auch noch äh.
Noch in Europa.
Jetzt auch mal in Europa mit frischem Terror und äh das volle Programm. Tja, und die Reaktionen sind super, wie man sie kennt, das eigentlich wenig,
Überraschung im Spiel.
Ja, Frankreich hat ja jetzt irgendwie den Ausnahmezustand verlängert. Ähm selbstverständlich wurde dann der,
die Lobpreisung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
laut insbesondere auch in Deutschland. Stellvertretende Vorsitzende der Gewerkschaft der Polizei, Jörg Radeck hat jetzt äh,
Dann natürlich sofort am Samstag äh betont, diese die immer wieder auflebende, unsinnige Debatte über den sogenannten Überwachungsstaat dürfe,
Der Vorratsdatenspeicherung nicht im Wege stehen. Nötig sei eine intensive Nachrichtendienstliche und polizeiliche Überwachung potentieller Gefährder.
Vielleicht sollten wir doch nochmal kurz, äh weil du weißt ja, Podcast werden ja auch in fünfhundert Jahren nochmal gehört.
Ja, man muss dazu sagen, Frankreich hat seit zweitausendsechs Vorratszeitenspeicherung und zwar mit ein Jahr Speicherdauer, ne, also ähm,
Es gab da tatsächlich, ich meine, diesmal waren sogar die,
in meiner, in meiner Wahrnehmung, in meiner Twitterwahrnehmung, die Vorratsdatenspeicherungsgegner schneller als die Vorratsdatenspeicherungsbefürworter,
die Gegner schon sofort gesagt, hier Vorratsseitenspeicherung hat nix gebracht. Ist natürlich ähm.
Warte mal, ich würde den Gedanken gern noch kurz ausführen. Ist interessant zu sehen, dass ähm gerade bei so einem.
Event sich also niemand,
Habe ich jetzt gesehen, ist er an irgendeiner Form des Umdenkens interessiert, ja? Also es wird einfach äh irreflexhaft,
Die Agenda abgearbeitet, ne? Das gab's ja also ähm,
kommen dann alle und sagen dann, was weiß ich, ne? Also was haben wir alles? Vorratsdatenspeicherung, äh Ausländer sind schuld, ne. Also die
Geflüchteten, dann gab's ja dann auch irgendwie wieder irgendwelche Ideen, die Geflüchteten waren darunter. Ähm wir brauchen äh mehr Polizei und Geheimdienstbefugnisse,
Computerspiele wurden jetzt auch schon beschuldigt, weil irgendwie angeblich die mit einer Playstation kommuniziert hatten. Dann äh geht man hin und fordert einen Bundeswehreinsatz im Inneren. Äh gibt's da irgendwelche Leute, die sich dann jetzt Bitcoin soll's jetzt auch ans Leder gehen, ne?
Ähm.
Alle Standardforderungen kommen wieder raus, alle Standardverteidigung kommen wieder raus und wir sind mittendrin in in einer Debatte, die wir eigentlich schon die ganze Zeit hatten.
Um nicht unvollständig zu sein, möchte ich zumindest nochmal kurz zusammenfassen, was eigentlich passiert ist.
Auch wenn's vielleicht alle wissen, aber einfach um auch mal die Faktenlage nochmal äh sozusagen auch dahin zu stellen. Es hat Anschläge gegeben in Paris,
Irgendwie eine noch nicht genau festgelegte Zahl von Personen hat an verschiedenen Stellen dieser Stadt Angriffe gefahren,
Es macht den Eindruck, dass es sich hierbei, ja, um eine islamistische Terrorgruppe handelt, die in irgendeiner Form,
Mit dem IS zusammenhängt, aber was halt das Interessante dabei ist, dass es sich hierbei nahezu ausschließlich um,
bürgereuropäischer Staaten handelt, vor allem Frankreich. Belgien, also keine,
eingereisten, durchgeschmuggelten Flüchtlinge, die jetzt im Rahmen des Flüchtlingsstroms vor zwei Wochen äh ins Land gekommen wären, sondern,
Leute, die hier geboren wurden, hier groß geworden sind, also hier in Europa,
Und die äh ja, weiß ich nicht. Aus anderen Umständen ihre Motivation abgeleitet haben, die wir sicherlich nur begrenzt verstehen können,
Aber die eben offensichtlich stattgefunden haben. Das heißt, es ist sozusagen auch nicht ein Angriff von außen, sondern es ist ein Angriff von innen.
Sicherlich mit Beteiligung von außen und wenn's nur,
ideologischer Beteiligung äh ist oder Ausbildung in fernen Terrorcamps oder was auch immer da im Einzelnen noch involviert gewesen sein mag. Trotzdem haben wir äh es jetzt wieder mit einer,
Regierung zu tun, die halt,
aufspringt und äh in bester Tradition von George David Busch einen Krieg gegen den Terror ausruft. Das Wort war schnell am Start,
Nach den Anschlägen gegen war diese Rhetorik so nicht. Ähm im Vordergrund, zumindest nicht, was äh Franova Holland äh betraf. Jetzt allerdings,
ein paar Wahlen an in den nächsten Wochen keine Ahnung ob das ein Einfluss gehabt hat Tatsache ist jetzt wird wieder Krieg geführt und die erste Maßnahme war dann eben gleich,
Bombardierungen in Syrien, was wir ja wissen, immer super viel bringt, ne, also umso mehr man im Nahen Osten bombardiert, umso friedlicher wird ja die Welt,
Ja und natürlich jetzt kommen halt äh die üblichen Verdächtigen um die Ecke und fordern das, was sie schon immer gefordert haben, was aber einfach überhaupt nicht äh,
ja passt, was einfach mal äh mit denen bis mit den Realitäten, wie sie sich bisher abzeichnen, einfach überhaupt nicht deckungsgleich sind.
Ja, es wird gefordert, man hätte ja nicht äh man bräuchte ja eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung, um zu überwachen, aber man hatte ja schon eine, die ist sogar vor kurzem noch erweitert worden nach den Anschlägen von,
auf und ja,
Da stehen wir jetzt und diskutieren wieder den gleichen Kram, wie auch schon letzte Woche Verbot von Verschlüsselung, obwohl es klare Berichte gibt, dass hier überhaupt gar keine Verschlüsselung groß ähm zum Einsatz kam, zumindestens äh,
stinknormale SMS verwendet worden, um die Attacken zeitlich zu koordinieren, et cetera. Gut, sicherlich war jetzt diese SMS nicht unbedingt auch äh im Wesentlichen,
Das, woraus man hätte irgendwas ableiten können, aber es ist äh sozusagen, es sind einfach Nebenkriegsschauplätze,
die immer wieder eröffnet werden, um die politische Agenda äh in die eigene gewünschte Linie zu bringen.
Äh es spielt ja dabei auch in der Tat eine Rolle, dass,
du jetzt als Verantwortlicher der Regierung, was weiß ich, als Innenminister oder sonst was.
Den Eindruck aufrechterhalten musst, dass du in der Lage bist derart ungemach.
In Zukunft zu verhindern.
Also musst du dir im Zweifelsfall auch irgendeinen Strom ansuchen, den du abfackeln kannst, ne?
Sonst müsstest du dich hinstellen und sagen einen Teil äh meiner Antworten würde die Bevölkerung verunsichern.
Interessant finde ich hier nochmal dieses äh Verschlüsselungsverbot. Das wird in Deutschland nicht diskutiert. Kommen wir nachher nochmal zu. Aber in Frankreich und in den USA ist das jetzt wieder in vollem Gange, ne?
Erstens, gibt's, wie gesagt, eine ähm Studie, die erstmal belegt, es gibt keinen Anstieg
in der Nutzung von Verschlüsselungen unter Dschihadisten seit es jetzt irgendwie seit Snowden ähm,
an die Öffentlichkeit gegangen ist, das war natürlich auch, ne, die Hardcore äh Rechten, Amerikaner, die haben natürlich sofort äh irgendwie sich hingestellt und gesagt, habt ihr gesehen, was snowden jetzt getan hat, ja, war jetzt Edward Snowden erstmal schuld. Ähm.
Ja, die Studie hat Foren abgegrast,
sozusagen einfach äh die üblichen ähm ja Social Media und, und, und, und webbasierten äh Diskussionsorte dieser Szenen äh untersucht und keinen Anstieg an Debatten über Verschlüsselung oder,
gefunden.
Ähm,
zu zu dieser äh Forderung würde ich eigentlich gerne nur nochmal überhaupt zu dieser Verschlüsselungsverbot, weil wir da auch schon mal vor, also wir haben ja schon mehrmals drüber gesprochen.
Ja, letzte Mal Cameron.
Genau. Diese die Sache mit der Verschlüsselung ist so.
Sichere Kommunikation gibt's entweder für alle oder für niemanden. Ja, also selbst wenn man das,
Also diese Idee, wir verbieten das jetzt den Terroristen oder so, ne. Ist natürlich sowieso schon mal äh totaler Quatsch. Ja, also,
Das geht eben nicht, ne? Aber das heißt, wenn du sagst, wir möchten jetzt irgendwie Verschlüsselung schwächen, wir wollen die so halten, dass der Staat sie knacken kann,
dann hat eben auch niemand,
Sichere Kommunikation und dann sind eben auch alle angreifbar. Und du kannst nicht technisch deine Unterscheidung treffen nach demjenigen, äh nach derjenigen Personengruppe, die sie nutzt. Zweitens,
gibt es,
Diese Mathematik nun mal und sie kommt, findet Anwendung und diese äh Kryptopaste bekommt man auch nicht wieder zurück in die Tube. Das heißt, ein Verschlüsselungsverbot würde dazu führen,
dass äh nur noch Terroristen,
Verschlüsselung haben. Interessanterweise oder Kriminelle oder diejenigen, die es halt können, ja? Interessanterweise ist das,
Ein ähnliches Argument wie bei Waffen.
Wo die Amerikaner, die Libertären, Amerikaner ja immer sagen, haha äh das heißt, wenn du wenn du,
Waffen verbietest, dann haben nur noch,
Äh die gesetzelosen Waffen, nur noch die Bösen. Deswegen müssen Waffen allen erlaubt sein, damit die Guten sie auch haben. Ähm.
Stimmt natürlich nicht, weil die Polizei also ich meine, je nachdem, ob man die Polizei jetzt so sagt, den Guten zuordnen möchte oder nicht, aber ist ja nicht so, dass man sich sozusagen aller Waffen entledigen würde in dem Fall.
Es gab auch irgendwie äh schrieb, glaube ich, äh kurz nach dem nach den Angriffen in Frankreich. Äh ja, stellt euch mal vor, da werden jetzt äh fünfzehn Leute mit einer gewesen. Ähm,
In den USA sind in einigen Bundesstaaten so, dass du letztendlich diese Cowboy-Mentalität. Du darfst eine Waffe tragen, aber die muss sichtbar sein.
Ja, also die haben die reglementieren, dass verdeckte Tragen von Waffen. Ja, also du quasi du kannst
Wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe. Ich kenne ja die die du kannst quasi mit einer Waffe in der Öffentlichkeit rumrennen, kannst die besitzen, kannst sie wie so ein Sheriff am äh am Gürtel tragen, ja? Aber wenn du die unter Mantel hast, ja, dafür brauchst du halt eine
eine Erlaubnis, dass es dann halt
unerlaubtes Tragen einer versteckten Waffe, weil wer auch immer mit dir zankt vorher nicht weiß, dass du jederzeit in der Lage bist, ihn zu töten. Ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen die die Idee dahinter. So, der.
Die texanische Form der Handytasche, ja?
Genau, der geht halt davon, äh sagt halt so, ja, wie wäre das denn, äh wenn da jetzt einfach, ne, ein paar Leute im Publikum gewesen wären, die zurückschießen? Auch eine interessante Überlegung. Äh ich glaube, das Problem ist einfach nur,
Also vielleicht hast du dann tatsächlich irgendwie so ein paar Cowboys im Publikum, die dann das Feuer eröffnen, ja. Das Problem ist, die,
Der Hasser war wahrscheinlich auch genug Chaos im Publikum bei jeder dritten Gelegenheit, das äh das Feuer eröffnen, wenn die da irgendwie mal ein Bier über die über die Bluse gegossen wird oder so, ne. Also die grundsätzliche Idee,
Frieden mit mit Waffen zu schaffen ist glaube ich in der Geschichte noch nicht,
besonders äh belegt und wir die Onion auch letzte Woche ähm,
feature ähm mahnen Historiker an, äh sich ihrer Zunft zu bedienen und sich in der Vergangenheit quasi sich der Vergangenheit zu bemächtigen und sich zu überlegen, wenn Entscheidungen in der Vergangenheit, ja,
nicht zu gewünschten Ergebnissen geführt haben, dass man quasi daraus für die Zukunft ableiten könnte,
genau diese Entscheidungen nicht mehr zu treffen, sondern andere. Quasi aus Fehlern der Vergangenheit für die Zukunft zu lernen.
Spannend, spannend. Absolute Querdenker.
Unglaublich.
Also was man auch so etwas, was in der Idee für ein Potential steckt, ja?
Ja. Nur Satire, das muss man jetzt nicht weiter drauf eingehen.
Ja, genau.
Wie diese Sendung ja auch.
So, dann äh meldete sich.
Mit einem mit einem Video ähm haben wir unglaublich viele Anfragen auch beim äh CCC dazu bekommen.
Ja, dann waren sie alle. Also da war wirklich.
Also ich habe mal geguckt, die haben sich auch nicht nur mit einem Video gemeldet, sondern da gab's irgendwie leicht so ein Wildwuchs. Ich meine, das ist ja auch immer dieselbe Mache.
Also das das Krisentelefon beim CCC stand nicht still,
die E-Mails ballerten äh rein.
Es gibt dann doch die Nummer.
Wieso kriegt der Lothar die.
Der Lothar sowieso nicht, wenn dann der Tommy. Ähm die.
Was werden die Hacker jetzt tun? Wer wird enorm bis jetzt, ne? Die Terroristen oder so. Tja, also ich habe da keine äh doch eine dieser Anfragen habe ich beantwortet.
Und der erste Satz, der mir da so in den Sinn kam, ist Hunde, die bellen beißen nicht. Also jemand, der.
Ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass es Hacker gibt, von mir aus auch im Kreise von Enorm ist, die ähm Fähigkeiten oder Informationen haben.
Um den tatsächlich irgendwie äh Schaden zuzufügen.
Aber wenn du dich im Moment.
Also ich meine, die Isis, die bellt natürlich ordentlich und die beißt auch, also bitte? Isis bellt ordentlich und beißt auch.
Genau, die Isis bellt und beißt, ja? Aber du du bellst nicht vorher. So die also,
blöder blöder äh Einwurf jetzt. So, wenn du ernsthaft hingehst und sagst, ich bin ein Hacker, ja, und ich werde mich jetzt mit Leuten anlegen,
irgendwie,
Kopf abschneiden für 'ne völlig legitime Form der politischen Auseinandersetzung halten und irgendwie weiß ich nicht wie viel Menschen auf dem Gewissen haben und gerade in kriegerische bewaffnete Handlungen an
X Fronten in einem Krisengebiet äh,
verwickelt sind. Wenn du dich mit denen anlegst, ne, dann machst du das nicht über YouTube. Ja, und die erste Erfolgsmeldung, die dann da jetzt irgendwie äh gestern,
stattfand, war dann auch eben, sage ich mal, eher äh äh,
ernüchternd ähm enormes hätte also fünftausendfünfhundert ISIS Accounts äh.
Abgeschaltet, ja? In sozialen Netzwerken. Ja, das ist.
Accounts, was für Accounts?
Ja. Ja genau, das steht auch schon direkt in dem Artikel nicht mehr drin. Äh stattdessen gibt es irgendwie ausführliche Äußerungen von einem Sprecher von Enorm ist, der also sagte,
unsere Möglichkeit Isis äh,
also zu Take-Down. Ich weiß nicht, was ist der zu sperren.
Herunterzufahren.
Herunterzufahren ist ein direktes Ergebnis unserer kollektiven äh äh,
erfahrenen Hacker, unseren und unseren Spionen, die wir überall auf der Welt haben. Wir haben Leute, die sehr, sehr nah äh bei bei ISIS sind und äh das macht es so einfach äh,
Intelligence, über ISIS und ihre Aktivitäten zu sammeln,
Und jetzt haben sie halt fünftausendvierhundert Accounts blocken lassen, ja. Ähm die geben es gibt keine Angaben darüber, wie oder welche.
Also und ich frage mich auch ernsthaft so, ich meine, Oma, Twitter-Account wurde gesperrt. Scheiße, jetzt habe ich's mit äh Nonnomes zu tun. Jetzt ziehe ich jetzt begeh ich doch keinen Selbstmordattentat mehr. Also ich meine.
Ich habe auch irgendwie aufm falschen Kriegs gebissen, was? Ich verstehe das nicht. Was ist denn das überhaupt? Dieses Anonymus.
Das ist vielleicht auch der, der, der, das, was man da nochmal zu sagen muss. Also, in Nondem ist prinzipiell,
jeder und die Idee, da kann äh
kann man einfach so ein äh Video online stellen. Das sind auch immer die gleichen, das ist das ist immer das gleiche Bild und dann irgendwie so eine Computer Generation Voice, das machst du irgendwie mit einem hier mit.
Fertig aus.
Mitm Magdex tospeach, ein bisschen fertig. Ähm musst du noch hochladen auf YouTube. Ähm.
Entscheidend ist, okay, Ideen und Operationen starten im mit dem Labels kann jeder und jede.
Ähm entscheidend ist, ob du nachher äh die Feuerkraft entwickelst, dass eben auch alle diese diesem Aufruf folgen, das ist hier jetzt der Fall gewesen. Und ich kann das auch sehr gut verstehen, dass ähm,
ähm da vielleicht auch,
sich in der Pflicht sieht, jetzt hier wieder im Heldenkostüm anzutreten. Äh was sie ja durchaus in, in, in Jahren zuvor öfter gemacht haben und dann auch
sehr viel Presseaufmerksamkeit bekommen haben, wie wie dieses Mal auch, ja? Ähm.
Ja aber mir fällt da irgendwie nichts mehr zu ein. Ich meine, hatten wir nicht hier irgendwie auch schon unseren unseren äh
der irgendwie äh auch schon irgendwie die islamische Welt im Alleingang äh äh niederringen wollte, das war doch genau dieselbe Nummer. Und äh
überhaupt sich dann auch einfach auch noch gleich in diese äh Kriegsrhetorik so mit rein äh zu spannen, ohne Not. Ja, die sagen wir mal, mit den,
Eigentlich ursprünglich,
existierenden Ansätzen dieser Anonymus-Bewegung, die er sozusagen auch sehr viel mehr in dieser äh Netzfreiheits äh Richtung geboren ist.
Da sehe ich irgendwie überhaupt gar keine Verbindung mehr. Also das ist einfach nur noch und wichtig äh Tuerei ohne irgendeine Verankerung in in in irgendwas und vor allem ohne eine klare,
Linie, ja?
Tja, klare Linie hat ein, hatte in Nonne bis jetzt noch nie unbedingt, das ist ja auch ein bisschen deren Stärke, aber man fragt sich halt wirklich, was was sie denn machen wollen, ne. Also sich da jetzt zu brüsten man habe fünftausendvierhundert Accounts heruntergeholt,
und noch nicht mal eine Angabe darüber zu machen, wie das denn geschehen ist, ja? Ähm.
Ganz am Anfang fand ich hatte das eine eine kleine Linie.
Gut mag sein, aber vielleicht kurz mal hier bei bei dieser nicht vorhandenen Linie jetzt bleiben. Ich erinnere mich an einen Bekannten,
der sich irgendwann mal auf Twitter ähm was weiß ich.
Negativ oder was auch immer in zum Thema IS äh geäußert hatte und der dann auf irgendwelchen langen Listen auf Pace bin auftauchte.
Wo Isis halt irgendwie sagten so, ja hier das ist jetzt hier der Feind der des ähm Propheten oder sowas, ne und der bekam dann auch äh,
Besuch von äh hier so Behörden, ne? Sicherheitsbehörden in Deutschland, die sagten so, ja guten Tag, wir wollten dir nur sagen, sie sind auf der Liste von Isis. Machen sie mal die Vorhänge zu. So ungefähr,
aber wir können ihnen auch nicht helfen so, ne? Da ist natürlich auch Verunsicherung, ja.
Genau. Vielleicht schreiben sie schon mal ihr Testament vor.
Wenn was ist, hier haben sie eine Krisennummer.
Ja aber aber äh was soll ich denn jetzt machen? Ja, das können wir ihnen nicht sagen, weil das würde sich nur verunsichern.
Ja, also äh ja, ich ich frage mich auch ernsthaft, ich meine, die sind offensichtlich ein bisschen anders drauf, als ein paar äh also ich meine, dass, ich glaube, die sind relativ,
Immun dagegen, äh ob ihnen jetzt mein Twitter-Account platt gemacht wird, ne?
Na ja, egal. Also, äh gibt es und äh sicherlich gut gemeint.
An dieser Stelle, weil das jetzt.
Dass es sich dabei nur um einen PR-Stand handelt, wäre sicherlich äh eine zu weitgehende Unterstellung.
Also ich will auch noch mal ich weiß ja nicht so ganz genau, aber ich habe so den Eindruck, äh,
so in unserem erweiterten Umfeld, ja, mag es sicherlich,
Den oder die eine geben, die irgendwie mit diesem ganzen Kaspertum irgendwie.
Meint zur harmonisieren, ja? Also,
Das das kann ja durchaus so, ja, so Jugend, Bewegung und das war ja auch einfach mal total hip und das klingt ja auch so toll und wir sind ja irgendwie Legion und rechnet mit uns und das ist also wirklich so ein
äh hormonell aufgeblasenes Getue,
Und wenn man sich halt diesen Quatsch anhört, wir verlinken da auch mal so eins von diesen albernen Videos, die sie da jetzt rausgebracht haben dazu. Das sind halt auch, also es ist auch einfach vollkommen verstört, ja, die,
plappern dann halt irgendwie, ja, von Force Fleck Operations und ob IS denn nicht dann doch irgendwie eine Erfindung äh der Westmächte wäre und so weiter. Da komme ich mir schon wirklich vor, wie bei so einer Pegida-Demo,
ähm und das das ist auch, sagen wir mal so generell so ein,
extrem verstörender Trend. Also es ist da einfach so Leute oder auch hier so diese diese Montagsdemos und und und,
FM, diese ganzen verlorenen Seelen, die irgendwie einfach nur noch rumrudern und alles mit allem vermischen, mit irgendwie Judenhass und, und, und, und was nicht alles. Ähm.
Um dann irgendwie am Ende äh irgendwie die russische Staatspropaganda irgendwie so als als Quell der Wahrheit auszumachen. Da da atme ich einfach nur noch schwer. So.
Jetzt hast du aber auch einen großen Bogen gespannt.
Ja, ich habe ja nur abgelegt, was was da sozusagen sich einfach täglich ausbreitet in in diesem Ganzen war. Das das macht ja alles keinen Sinn
genau deswegen, ja, aber solche sogenannten Argumentationsketten finden sich halt auch in diesen Videos wieder,
Es ist einfach äh verstörend so, also dass das mal einfach mal bleiben mit diesem ganzen Anonymus Quatsch, das ist einfach Unfug,
da steht nichts dahinter, das ist einfach alles nur noch ein ein Schatten einer Idee, die irgendwann mal geboren wurde, äh im Kampf gegen sein,
Ja und das war in Sommer mal noch,
Tolle Sachen, ja, aber auch mit dieser albernen äh äh Maske oder irgendwelche katholischen Terroristen mit glorifiziert werden, das passt einfach auch alles und vorne nicht zusammen. Also es ist einfach verquer wie nur sonst irgendwas und,
Bitte. Danke.
Ich würde nur gerne nochmal kurz darauf hinweisen, dass eben,
jeder ein enormes Video veröffentlichen kann und dann eben auch Leute, die für queere Ideen haben, das heißt aber jetzt grundsätzlich nicht, dass äh alle, die bei nicht grundsätzlich das Aldi bei enormem sind, äh diese Ideen auch teilen, ne. Also das.
Nee, aber dieser Brand ist halt einfach abgefackelt. Also da, da, da, da, da kann man einfach nix
ausrichten, dass es einfach durch und bewegen wollt, dann dann denkt euch was Neues aus und findet vor allem eine eine Position und eine Linie, die sich auch einfach mal äh historisch, politisch irgendwie auch herleiten äh äh lässt und die für humane
eine humanitäre äh Werte äh äh steht und, und, und dann macht was Neues draus, aber aber das Ding ist einfach wirklich nur noch albern,
Das ist einfach Unfug. So, sonst machen wir nämlich auch noch hier nochmal ein anderes Nimus-Video.
Jetzt aber ab.
Ich mache das mal, diese Folge zu Ehren von zu Ehren von der Nonne, wir müssen manchmal diese Folge mit mit Video, das ist ja und dieses Manaken ein.
Genau. Wir schreiben die Sendung auf und dann gibt's das hier alles nur noch Textes,
Expect Ass! Wir sind Legion.
Okay, komm. Mann, ey, weißt du, was wir jetzt wieder in den Kommentaren auf die Schnauze krieg.
Scheiß drauf, muss ja auch mal gesagt werden.
Das wird man ja wohl noch sagen.
Sagen dürfen, genau.
Hast du das? Also wenn du jetzt hier schon den so.
Ne, ich will einfach, ich will einfach, dass, dass dass die Leute, die einfach auch wirklich bereit sind, äh,
Action zu zeigen, dass dass sie sich halt nicht einfach in so einem Quatsch einordnen, sondern dass sie halt einfach selber denken und und und ne, überzeugende Aktionen bringen und,
Auch genug Beispiele geliefert in den letzten Monaten. Es gibt solche äh Aktionen, denkt euch auch selber was aus und dann geht's auch voran. So, jetzt bin ich ruhig.
Was ist denn im.
BND, beim BND, möchtest du übern BND reden?
Hm? Bitte. Ist mein Lieblingsthema.
Der BND. Ähm es gibt jetzt viele Meldungen über Selektoren und zwar ähm.
Endlich.
Irgendwie so eingebürgert hat. Das finde ich eigentlich echt spannend, dass dass es.
Dass alle von, ja, Selektor, Selektoren. Diese Selektoren mappen immer auf ähm,
Zielperson, ne? Also ja, Selektor ähm oder die mappen auf Offsie Person oder Zielunternehmen, Spionageziele, ein,
Selektor ist ein Spionage-Ziel. Ja, das könnte mit dem Begriff könnte man durchaus da verwenden, statt diesen äh irgendwie eine technische Komponente
ähm verklärende
Begrifflichkeit des Selektors aus der NSA-Sprache zu übernehmen. Aber egal. Es gibt Debatten um Selektoren
Der gute Herr Graulich,
hat Selektoren begutachtet, die äh gegen deutsche oder europäische Interessen verstoßen haben und deshalb vom BND aussortiert wurden. In den Meldungen der letzten Tage.
Äh geht es äh äh Entschuldigung, ähm der Graulich hatte die Selektoren, die der,
die die NSA den BND gegeben hat, die deshalb aussortiert wurden. In diesen Debatten.
Nein, nein, der Graulich hatte nur die, die aussortiert wurden vom BND.
Oh Mann, Entschuldigung, ja. Die der BND aussortiert hat und von der NSA bekommen hat. So, es gibt aber noch weitere selektoren,
die der BND quasi selber eingepflegt hat und die gegen deutsche und europäische Interessen verstoßen haben. Diese wurden,
Das hatte der gute Herr Schindler schon vor drei bis vier Wochen im ähm NSA Untersuchungsausschuss eingeräumt, dass ja vielleicht auch mal der ein oder andere Freund hups aus Versehen mit in die lange Selektorenliste hätte gehabt, Gesang hätte gekonnt,
ja? Das hat der eingeräumt. So und jetzt haben die äh wurden neunhundert Seiten Selektoren,
vom BND für die äh für eine,
Task Force des parlamentarischen Kontrollgremiums äh zusammengestellt und,
äh das, die wurde jetzt also angeschaut von diese neunhundert Seiten wurden dem äh Hans-Christian Ströbele, Uli Grotsch von der SPD und Armin Schuster von der CDU gegeben und die haben sich das,
Äh
angeschaut und die haben darin unter anderem Hans-Jörg Haber gefunden, der momentan EU-Botschafter in der Türkei ist und der als Deutscher.
Ähm natürlich vom äh Grundgesetz geschützt wird. Und bei der für dessen Überwachung der BND eine Genehmigung der G zehn-Konvention,
gebraucht hätte. Ähm auch Laurence Fabius oder den Fabi.
Yuss, verbliss.
Dann wären zwei S und N. Ich will sagen, Fabi. Aber egal.
Man trotzdem so.
Ja, wir gucken ja, ich gucke ja kein Fernsehen, ich lese das immer alles nur. Ähm.
Den äh französisch französischen Außenminister und bis zweitausenddreizehn, also bis äh Auftakt Snowden.
Waren äh unter anderem der internationale Strafgerichtshof,
dass UN-Kinderhilfsweg, UNICEF, die Weltgesundheitsorganisation WHO, die,
US-Bundespolizei FBI, der US-Auslandssender Voice of America und viele,
zahlreiche europäische und US-amerikanische Unternehmen, darunter auch Rüstungskonzerne, wie Lockheat,
Ziel des BND.
Völlig überraschend,
Und dann kam eine äh Reißleine vom vom Kanzleramt. Kurz nachdem Angela Merkel äh,
Schweiß sie ihres Angesichts gesagt hat, äh abhören unter Freunden, das geht gar nicht. Diese neue Doktrin äh wurde dann eben auch vom Kanzleramt in den äh BND heruntergereicht.
Glaube sogar kurz, bevor sie das gesagt hat. Aber egal. In dem Zeit.
Ich meine kurz danach, aber sagen wir, das wird jetzt da, das ist auch äh Haarspalterei. Diese neunhundert Seiten werden jetzt noch monatelang geprüft werden. Ähm,
Das Spannende ist, der Spiegel hat bereits Selektoren zitiert, die nicht in dieser Liste sind. Und jetzt ist die Frage, ob diese neunhundert Seiten, die jetzt da die Kontrolleure bekommen haben.
Äh unvollständig oder manipuliert sind. Diese Selektorenlisten sollen auch dem NSA Untersuchungsausschuss jetzt zugänglich gemacht werden. Das ist eine,
kann man als Kehrtwende bezeichnen, die haben ja sonst keine Selektoren bekommen. Das sollte jetzt, die werden sie also, ich glaube, am Montag oder so dann auch äh offiziell erhalten, sind werden dann auf dem gleichen,
Stand sein, äh wie die restlichen Kollegen vom äh von der Task Force des Parlament.
Womit die Bundesregierung ja sozusagen jetzt nachgibt in dieser äh Debatte, da die äh Abgeordneten,
im Untersuchungsausschuss der Oppositionsparteien ja angekündigt haben, dagegen klagen zu wollen. Ich weiß nicht, ob diese Klage jetzt trotzdem stattfindet. Ich vermute mal ja.
Ist da, ich weiß nicht genau, was da der Stand ist. Wir reden nämlich von anderen Selektoren, das an der ursprünglich. Die Klage bezog sich ja,
mitunter auf diese Graulichselektoren. Und hier geht es jetzt um äh mitunter um die auf die Graulichselektoren, die NSA Selektoren und hier geht es jetzt um Selbst vom BND eingepflegte Selektoren.
Ich weiß nicht genau, äh und ich glaube, das ist auch Teil der Informationspolitik oder der.
Wie soll man das sagen, der der äh Missinformation, der Verwirrung,
dass dass man überhaupt nicht mehr weiß, was es überhaupt für Selektoren gibt und von welchen da die Rede ist. Diese bekommt er in NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss jetzt schon mal, ja, der schon mal ganz lustig. Spannend ist,
Erste politische Konsequenzen,
stehen am Horizont, Clemens Bing Bininger von der CDU, Burkhardt Lischkaff, von der SPD wollen,
Im Januar in Gesetzesentwurf einbringen, den sie dann möglichst bis zum Sommer zweitausendsechzehn durchhaben wollen. Ähm,
und die sagen, sie wollen das BND-Gesetz ändern, sodass ähm,
Spionage im europäischen Ausland und bei EU-Institutionen nur noch in begründeten Einzelfällen erlaubt ist,
Er begründete Einzelfälle sind Verdacht auf terroristische Aktivitäten, Umgehung von Rüstungsembargus und organisierte Kriminalität.
Also Hütchenspieler.
Werden das jetzt, also wollen das jetzt verbieten und äh Dienst und Fachaufsicht des BND sollen gestärkt werden, ja. Ähm es gibt äh.
Die Abteilung sechstes äh Kanzleramt, die äh diese Aussicht hat und die soll äh künftig jede Maßnahme der strategischen Fernmeldeaufklärung des BND.
Vom BND-Präsidenten genehmigen und,
Entschuldigung, also jede Maßnahme der strategischen Fern meldet, Aufklärung des BND soll vom BND-Präsidenten selbst angeordnet und vom Kanzleramt genehmigt werden und deswegen wird jetzt Abteilung äh sechs gestärkt. Ja, um sicherzustellen, dass da,
dass der BND da nicht frei dreht. Keine Ahnung, ob das, ob derartige ähm.
Komische organisatorische Veränderungen ernsthaft jemals sich wirklich in der Praxis,
der Realität dann niederlassen. Ich habe auch keine genaue Ahnung, ob sowas jetzt überhaupt möglich ist, was sie sich da vorstellen. Aber immerhin.
Möglich im Sinne von rechtlich möglich oder im Sinne von.
Organisatorisch möglich, ja. Und.
Ja. Und vor allem, was heißt das Kanzleramt, heißt das dann, der für die Geheimdienste.
So ein puffer, ne?
Der der dann.
Das machen wir jetzt nicht noch einmal.
Dann wollen sie noch das Gesetz über das parlamentarische Kontrollgremium um einen Geheimdienst beauftragen erweitern, soll's also einen ständigen Bevollmächtigen geben,
der die Arbeit der Überwacherinnen, Überwachen und die Kontrollgremien Kontrollgremien koordinieren soll,
Denn es gibt nicht nur das parlamentarische Kontrollgremium, die, sondern auch die G zehn Kommission ähm,
Dass äh die äh also G zehn, ne, Grundgesetz, Artikel zehn, äh die also Eingriffe in das Briefpost- und Fernmeldegeheimnis überwacht. Äh,
stattfinden in der Arbeit des BND, des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz und des Militärischen ab. Schirmdienstes,
und das Vertrauensgremium des Haushaltsausschusses
Ja, da soll also jetzt einer, also diese Gremien sind sowieso überlastet und kriegen nix hin. Äh Hans-Christian Ströbel, der hat uns da ja durchaus einiges von erzählt, wie die, wie die also auch immer hinters Licht geführt werden. Und die sollen also jetzt irgendwie einen,
Koordinator dazubekommen, der sich um alles kümmern soll. Auch da kann ich mir irgendwie nicht vorstellen, dass das jetzt eine Änderung ist, die wirklich.
Entscheidend den Tank herumreißt, auf das er sich in Zukunft signifikant anders verhalte,
Aber ich habe diesen Gesetzesentwurf jetzt auch nicht in seiner Ausformulierung gesehen und ähm wir sind gespannt.
Ist auch nur angekündigt. Ja, ist auch ein bisschen äh merkwürdig, weil so wie es sich bisher abzeichnet in der Berichterstattung, ist hier von einer Position die Rede, die förmlich bedeuten würde, dass diese Person dem,
PKGR unterstellt ist, der dann aber trotzdem koordinieren soll. Ja, also was ist das an so einer Art,
Best Boy, so, jemanden, den man so rumschicken, den ganzen Tag alle anruft oder, oder wie? Also, es ist, klingt mehr so nach einer bürokratischen Hilfe, anstatt nach irgendeiner erweiterten,
Kompetenz. Kommt wohl auch bei der Opposition nicht so richtig gut an der Plan. Überraschenderweise.
Tja, unklar. Liebe Kerze vielleicht, vielleicht auch nicht, wir wissen's nicht.
Werden wir auch erstmal sehen, aber äh interessant finde ich schon mal vielleicht dem Ganzen auch noch, um etwas positives abzugewinnen. Ähm.
Es scheint sich zumindest schon soweit entwickelt zu haben, dass die Bundesregierung das Gefühl hat, es müsse was geschehen,
Also ob jetzt irgendwas geschieht, was auch im Sinne der Debatte ist, sei mal dahingestellt, aber äh man ist da, glaube ich, etwas in die Defensive geraten.
Hm. Jetzt wenigstens mal was machen. Na ja.
Gibt's nicht sehr viel mehr zu zu sagen, oder? Nö, machen wir das auch nicht.
Nö. Wir sind gespannt. Dann gab es eine eine.
Muss man vielleicht noch ein bisschen aushören, wenn man das äh in letzten in letzter Zeit wenig behandelt haben. Also, es gibt das Anonymisierungs,
Projekt, Software, Tool, Netzwerk Thor. Ähm Thor funktioniert.
Im Prinzip folgendermaßen, wenn man sich mit dem Internet verbindet, also ich rufe, ihr ruft Logbuch Netzpolitik DE auf.
Dann weiß,
unser äh Server der Metaebene Server eure IP-Adresse. Es geht nicht anders, er muss euch ja antworten, soll ich ja etwas zurückschicken und dafür muss er wissen, wo er das hinschicken soll und daher weiß er eure IP-Adresse.
Und äh das kann natürlich unter äh bestimmten Umständen,
vielleicht mal nicht gewünscht sein. Gleichzeitig weiß nämlich auch euer Internetanbieter oder wer auch immer vielleicht eure Leitung überwacht
ähm dass ihr Logbuch Netzpolitik aufruft und damit natürlich offensichtlich äh nicht politisch,
auf Linie seid ist ein Selektor quasi ja? Könnte man sich jetzt vorstellen. So und um dieses Problem der,
Überwachung letztendlich zu lösen,
ähm gibt es das System Thor, in dem sich ähm viele Rechner zu einem ähm zu einer Art.
Zu einem immer wieder dynamisch sich ändernden Netz zusammenschließen und dafür sorgen, dass jeder äh jedes,
Paket, was man da quasi reinschickt,
mehrmals innerhalb dieses Netzes hin und her geschickt wird, bevor es wieder rauskommt. Warum tut man das? Also, du hast im Prinzip drei Notes, also dass die Entry Note,
und die Exit-Note,
in so einem Kanal, der dann für dich zur Anonymisierung äh genutzt wird. Die Entry-Note nimmt dein äh Paket entgegen und weiß, wer du bist,
Deine Daten sind aber jetzt noch,
zweimal weiter verschlüsselt, also sie sind einmal verschlüsselt mit dem Key der Entry Note. Das heißt, die Entry Note weiß, wer du bist. Dann das, was dann da drin ist, ist aber noch zweimal weiter verschlüsselt, nämlich.
Zunächst mit dem Keyder äh Middle Note. Diese Middle Note weist jetzt, wer deine Entry Note war, weiß aber schon nicht mehr, wer du bist.
Und Deep entpackt die Information und weiß äh und schickt es dann zu der nächsten Not.
Und diese ist dann im äh Regelfall die Exit-Note, die weiß dann also nur noch die Middle Note, weiß aber nicht mehr deine Entry Note, weiß aber weiß also auch nicht mehr, wer du bist.
Weiß aber dann, welche Art von Request du nach außen schicken möchtest. Ja, Logbuch Netzpolitik DE. Das heißt, ein äh,
Ein nicht vollumfänglicher Überwacher des Internets kann,
Quasi sehen, ah okay, ähm du nutzt Thor. Du bist hier in einer Entry-Note gegangen. Ähm weiß aber nicht, was du aufgerufen hast. Ähm der Überwacher der Exit-Note kann sehen, jemand,
hat Logbuch Netzpolitik besucht und wir können eben sehen, uns hat jemand besucht aus dem Tornetz. So funktioniert das,
Grob, ich habe das jetzt absichtlich mal versucht, einfach zu erklären. Jetzt.
Wurde das Tornetz im Laufe der Zeit um viele interessante ähm Features erweitert, unter anderem das Feature darin, versteckte Dienste anzubieten,
In dem Fall ist dein deine Not auch ein Server, bietet also selber ähm,
Eine Webseite oder einen Dienst an,
ohne dass das Tornetz verlassen wird. Das heißt, dein Request geht einfach nur in das Tornetz rein und,
Versickert darin, ja und kommt nicht an einer anderen Stelle wieder raus, sondern wird von von dem von einem Server innerhalb des Tornetzes beantwortet. Und das Schöne daran ist, dass diese hidden Services nicht nur.
Für dich erreichbar sind über diesen nur ausschließlich anonymisiert erreichbar sind sondern auch gegenüber den Nutzern oder potentiellen Angreifern ihren ihre wahre IP-Adresse nicht verraten müssen.
Und das bietet sich natürlich an für allerlei
sagen wir mal Dienste von erhöhtem Sicherheitsbedürfnis, wie zum Beispiel Plattformen wie jetzt Global Leaks oder SecureDrop nutzen, also hidden Services
um ähm erstens die einreichenden Whistleblower zu zwingen, ähm,
sich selber durch Anonymisierung äh von Tor zu schützen, andererseits um,
vielleicht auch die Angriffsfläche auf ihren Server gering zu halten. Gleichzeitig wurde dieses System der auch von den immer wieder berühmt gewordenen
Schwarzhandelsmarktplätzen im Internet genutzt. Ähm wie zum Beispiel äh Silk Road,
dieser sehr bekannte
Schwarzmarkt im Internet, dessen Betreiber lange Zeit nun in in den Knast gewandert ist, also nicht unbedingt für den Betrieb dieser Seite, sondern dafür, dass er allen möglichen anderen Mist noch ähm,
gebaut hat. So.
Und jetzt haben natürlich Strafverfolgungsbehörden in einigen mehreren Situationen, insbesondere im Rahmen von Ermittlungen.
Ein Interesse daran, solche Hidden Services anzugreifen. Und das kannst, kann man tun.
Wenn man an vielen Stellen Traffic.
Checken kann, ja? Also dieser dieser HIN Service befindet sich ja trotzdem noch unter einer normalen Adresse irgendwo im Internet und spricht halt im Idealfall nur mit dem Tornetz. So und durch wenn du nun geschickte äh Traffic ähm,
Analysen machst, kannst du ja zum Beispiel erkennen, ob dein äh Hidden Service,
den du de anonymisieren möchtest diesen Traffic verarbeitet oder nicht,
Oder zum Beispiel, du hast die Vermutung, dass folgende normale IP-Adresse im Internet dahinten Service ist, dann machst du halt eine Angriff auf diese IP und guckst, ob sie gleichzeitig im Tornetz an der Stelle dann platt ist oder ähnliches, ja?
So und da gibt's also äh ein starkes Interesse von äh Bundespolizeibehörden äh Angriffe deanonymisierungsangriffe auf Hidden Services zu fahren. Und,
Nun gab es vor ein oder zwei Jahren, das äh erinnere ich mich gar nicht mehr genau, ich glaube,
weiß ich jetzt nicht genau. Zeit vergeht so schnell. Eine Einreichung bei der Security Conference Blackhead, wo Forscher sagten, hey, wir,
präsentieren einen Angriff auf das Tornetz, zur Deanonymisierung von Hidden Services.
Dieser Vortrag wurde zurückgezogen. Das war damals irgendwie ein großes hin und her beim äh oder ein großer großes Thema innerhalb der Security-Szene, weil man eben nicht wusste, warum wurde der zurückgezogen? Wurde der zurückgezogen, weil,
Strafverfolgungsbehörden verboten haben, dieses Wissen öffentlich zu machen, äh wurde der zurückgezogen, weil äh die Sicherheitslücke nicht zu fixen ist, was auch immer, ja?
Und nun gab es letzte Woche eine Veröffentlichung von ähm.
Roger Dingeldein, dem Erfinder und einem einer der entscheidenden Vertreter von Thor, der dort die Vermutung äußerte, dass,
Das FBI, die Canegie Melon, Universität, bezahlt hat,
für einen Angriff auf das Hin-Servicesystem und dass dieser ähm im Rahmen eines äh einer koordinierten ähm.
Einer koordinierten äh wie einem Razzia gegen äh Hidden Services zum Einsatz kam. Dieser,
Angriff selbst, der da durchgeführt wurde, wurde von Tor schon im letzten Jahr veröffentlicht. Inklusive der Schritte, die sie äh unternommen haben, um einen derartigen Angriff zu,
erschweren oder potenziell gänzlich zu verhindern, gänzlich geht halt leider nicht, weil du eben, wie gesagt, immer die Möglichkeit hast, durch durch deinen eigenen Traffic einfach zu schauen, kommt der da an. Das Entscheidende ist aber, du brauchst dafür eine,
Hypothese, wo sich denn der ähm der Hinservice befindet, das heißt du brauchst 'ne,
Brauchst einen Verdacht und dann kannst du dich bemühen, diesen zu äh erhärten.
Das, was Tor jetzt daran kritisiert, ist, dass es keinen Hinweis gibt, dass äh das FBI in irgendeiner Form einen Durchsuchungsbefehl hatte,
oder irgendeine Form von ähm institutioneller Kontrolle, als sie da diese Universität ähm.
Angeheuert hat für diesen Angreif, für diesen Angriff. Und da ist, ist natürlich durchaus.
Bedenklich, wenn äh Security-Forschung ohne irgendwie ein ethisches Board oder so ähm in derartigen Angriffen zum Einsatz kommt.
Jetzt gab's eine Stellungnahme der Knegarnegime Universität, die sagte, ja,
Es gibt eine eine Anzahl äh in akkurater Medienberichte hier. Ähm,
unser äh Software-Engineering-Institut in Cyber-Security irgendwie was getan hätte, das stimmt so nicht.
Wir bekommen Geld vom Staat, um unsere Forschung durchzuführen.
Insbesondere natürlich auch Security-Forschung äh im Bezug auf Thor.
Und wir haben ein äh Computer-Emergency response Team, äh was wir hier auch unterhalten und äh was dafür da ist, äh solche Sicherheitszücken, wenn sie gefunden sind, zu beseitigen.
Im Rahmen dieser Arbeit wird die Universität von Zeit zu Zeit mit Sapinas ähm.
Äh Informationen über seine Forschung herauszugeben.
Wir sind in diesem Fall gezwungen, uns an die an das Gesetz zu halten und Gesetzmäßiges Gesetzmäßigen Sapinas zu entsprechen und erhalten kein Geld äh für,
diese ähm für das, für das für diese äh für das Entsprechen mit derartigen äh Requests. Das ist,
Eigentlich noch beunruhigender. Ja, also die Idee, dass die Uni für der Betrag, der da, von dem da die Rede war, war eine Million. Ja, das ist also quasi die Forscher ein Anruf vom FBI kriegen. Ey, helft uns mal hier diesen, diesen Torangriff zu machen.
Wir wollen ein paar Drogendealer hochnehmen. Hier habt ihr eine Million. Das ist schon beunruhigend. Noch beunruhigender ist,
Wenn das FBI da hingeht und sagt, ey hier, ihr seid eine Uni, wir bezahlen euch. Hier sind die äh wir wollen einmal wissen, wie euer Forschungsstand zu Torangriffen ist. Das ist äh letztendlich noch beunruhigender.
Ja, das heißt, man ist halt auch überhaupt nicht also man ist sozusagen in dem Moment, wo man sich der Security-Forschung äh hingibt, automatisch auch ausnutzbar. Genauso wie wir das bei den großen Unternehmen auch gesehen haben.
Das ist äh.
Ist äh krass und genau jetzt,
berahmen dieser Debatten, die jetzt gerade geführt werden über äh wir verbieten Krypto oder äh sonstige Scherze, ne? Und überhaupt, dass generelle Interesse von ähm,
Von Strafverfolgungsbehörden und äh Inlands Inlands- und Auslandsgeheimdiensten an Security-Schwächen, an Angriffen, an Exploits. Ähm.
Wir haben ja, wir kritisieren ja,
Durchaus regelmäßig den Exploit Handel, der da betrieben wird und der von den von den staatlichen Stellen auch so aufgeheizt wird, die da halt große Beträge zahlen für äh Sicherheitslücken, die sie dann nicht schließen, sondern zum äh,
zum Einsatz bringen oder ausnutzen. Aber wenn du jetzt unabhängige Forschungsinstitutionen, die ein Staat sich
leistet wie Universitäten mehr oder weniger einfach mit einem mit einem Sapina belegen können und sagen zack einmal rausrücken hier, wir müssen mal eben. Dann äh ist das für Sicherheitsforscher eine,
sehr ähm kritische Zukunft, in die wir da blicken.
Also ich stelle mir das gerade mal vor, also wenn jetzt, bin ja auch in dem Bereich tätig, wenn bei uns jetzt irgendwie.
BKA, das BKA vor der Tür stände und würde sagen hallo, wir haben gesehen, ihr beschäftigt euch mit dem und dem. Wir brauchen mal euren aktuellen Forschungsstand und eure äh euren Support. Wir müssen mal hier irgendwie dieses und jenes machen.
Und ihr dürft natürlich keinem davon erzählen.
Und genau und ihr dürftet keinem erzählen. Das ist schon echt äh patriotisch.
Echt patriotisch.
So. Facebook hat eine auf den Sack bekommen in Belgien.
Ja, na ja, aufn Sack. Bisschen so.
Die müssen halt ein bisschen was aus ihrer Portokasse rausschütteln.
Wenn sie äh nur wenn sie nur wenn sie weiterhin das tun, was sie jetzt tun.
Ich habe leider nicht mehr die Meldung gefunden, ob sie damit jetzt aufgehört haben oder nicht. Aber so ist das in einem Live-Podcast. Wir machen hier Live-Podcasting.
Wo denn?
Quasi. Live on Tape hieß das immer bei bei RTL Samstagnacht oder so. Live on Tape. Ähm soll der die ähm.
Großartig. Live on tap, das muss ich mir merken.
Ein großes Ärgernis ist ja dieser Facebook-Like-Button. Nicht nur, weil der überall ist und Platz wegnimmt.
Und nicht nur, weil er einen selber, wenn man sich bei Facebook angemeldet hat, in dem Moment auch als Person identifiziert, wenn man an der Seite lädt, wo der drauf ist.
Genau, sondern weil er das auch macht, wenn man kein Facebook Nutzer ist, wie ich zum Beispiel, ne? Kann ich jetzt, kann ich eigentlich auch nicht mehr aufrecht halten, die Behauptung. Äh äh ich habe ja eine Logbuch-Netzpolitik Facebook-Seite gemacht.
Na ja, vom Account Inhaber zum Nutzer ist schon nochmal ein kleines Stück. Account, also Accountinhaber bin ich auf so vielen Plattformen.
Danke Tim. Das ist jetzt meine Weltraumtheorie.
Also, ich benutze dich. Ich inhabe einen Account, aber es heißt noch lange nicht, dass ich den benutze, der ist ja äh das ist ja äh Internet.
Ich bin ja gar nicht im Internet. Ich bin ja ganz weit weg davon.
Genau, äh ich habe ja quasi jetzt äh okay, ähm.
So, überall ist dieser scheiß Like-Button und der äh ist im Prinzip die große,
Der Like-Button ist im Prinzip, was das Tracking von Nutzern angeht, oder Sammeln von Wissen über die Nutzer. Der Teil der der Facebook so viel stärker als Google macht.
Weil Facebook, Google ist im Prinzip da, Googles Interesse ist, du mögest doch bitte häufig googeln, damit sie gucken, was du suchst
wo du dann hinklickst, ja, mit dem wo du hinklickst, verbessern sie ihre Suchergebnisse, mit dem, was du suchst, verbessern sie ihre äh Werbung
die sie dir anbieten. Wenn du dich dann aber von dort aus weiterklickst, verliert Google deine Spur.
Nicht jedoch Facebook, denn sie haben äh dich sowieso in ihrem komischen äh Ding da gefangen und wenn du da mal aus Versehen aus dem Facebook rausfällst, dann ist da der ähm Facebook-Like-Button,
der vom Seitenbetreiber eingebettet wird und den Facebook dir dann als Nutzer zuliefert, ja?
Hätten wir haben wir ein Facebook-Like? Nee, nee. So, hätten wir einen auf Logbuch Netzpolitik, würde also Facebook jedes Mal, wenn du als Facebook, wenn jemand Logbuch Netzpolitik besucht, jedes Mal, würde Facebook auch davon Kenntnis erlangen.
Denn der Facebook-Like Button wird von Facebook geholt. So und jetzt geht Facebook hin und sagt,
Ja und jeder, der den Besuch, der kriegt einen Cookie.
Und äh das ist nicht nur ein Cookie, den Facebook verteilt. Ähm aber hier geht es um diesen spezifischen Cookie mit dem Namen Data DATR,
und der bleibt äh zwei Jahre aktiv, auch wenn der Nutzer Facebook verlässt, ja? Und.
So Track quasi Facebook alle Nutzer des Internetes,
die nicht jetzt äh die also unhygienisch sich im Internet bewegen und nicht äh mehrere äh Trackerblocker und AdBlocker haben, wie was weiß ich,
ähm was gibt's noch, damit wir jetzt mal ein paar genannt haben, Tim. Nehmen wir die beiden, reiche.
Ja so einiges.
Gibt viel. Ähm.
Also ein ungeschützter Internetnutzer ruft eben auch diesen diesen Facebook-Button immer auf und kriegt dann offenbar auch diesen Cookie. Und ähm die belgischen Datenschützer haben gesagt, ey ihr dürft personenbezogene Daten,
Internetnutzern nur nach eindeutiger Zustimmung der Betroffenen aufzeichnen. Wenn ihr eine derartige Zustimmung nicht habt, dann dürft ihr es auch nicht tun.
Mit anderen Worten, sie müssten einen von diesen, ja.
Wer nicht eurer Nutzer ist, der oft von dem habt ihr keine äh Dingens und deswegen dürft ihr die auch nicht tracken. Und jetzt ist interessant. Dann kam der Facebook-Sicherheitschef Alex Stamos,
und argumentierte, dieser Data-Cookie-Helfe falsche Profile von Facebook herauszufiltern und verhindere Cyberattacken,
Da denkst du dir natürlich so, okay, Moment mal, wie macht Facebook das denn?
Das Beispiel, was er nennt, ist, wenn ein Webbrowser,
binnen fünf Minuten hunderte Seitenbesuche, dann sei das ein klares Zeichen dafür, dass der Computer wohl von Online-Kriminellen gekapert worden sei.
Ähm Moment mal. Also wenn ich als Online-Krimineller einen Computer kapere,
und besuche dann mithilfe dieses Computers mehrere hundert Seiten innerhalb von fünf Minuten. Dann.
Mache ich das doch selbstverständlich nicht mit dem Webbrowser, der den ganzen Shit noch mitlädt, den ich sowieso nicht brauche und den ich hundertmal das Gleiche lade. Das mache ich doch, also
Abgesehen davon, dass ich jetzt grade keinen das mir jetzt gerade das Szenario fehlt, wo ein Online-Krimineller mein Computer kapert, um damit fünfhundert Seiten äh hunderte Seiten entbindet fünf Minuten zu besuchen
Aber wenn er diesen Anwendungszweck hätte, dann würde er doch irgendeinen Scraper nutzen und nicht den Firefox. Der der da läuft, ja, der mit allen Cookies belastet ist,
Ja, das Erste, was ich doch mache, ist, wenn ich irgendwie viele Seiten äh auf einmal besuchen will, aus welchem Grund auch immer, ist, dass ich den ganzen den ganzen das ganze Grund, den ganzen Spam da, nicht mitlade. Also das Erste, was ich mache, also ich nutze.
Schon schon gar nicht irgendwelche Cookies, die einen identifizieren.
Eben, also ein, eine schamlose, schamloser Bullshit.
Das ist wirklich frech, ey.
Und ich finde das unmöglich, dass wir jetzt hier drei Minuten verschwenden müssen unserer Lebenszeit und der unserer Hörer, um so einen böswilligen Unsinn äh richtig zu stellen. Ärgerlich.
Ärgerlich. Frechheit.
So. Also, wenn erstens.
Wenn ein Rechner binnen fünf Minuten, mehrere hundert Seiten besucht, kann man das auch feststellen, ohne einen Cookie. Ja, das sehen die an den an der IP-Adresse an besagter IP-Adresse, wenn derjenige so blöd ist und diese Facebook,
Button Mitläd, was er sowieso nicht tut. Ja.
Vor allem hunderte Seiten in fünf Minuten mit einem Webbrowser über dies äh.
Klassisches, klassisches Angriffsszenario erleben wir jeden Tag, Tim, siehst du heute? Internet ist voll von Leuten, die auf einmal sagen, Scheiße, ich wurde gehackt, jetzt habe ich hundert Seiten, binnen fünf Minuten besucht. Mist. Ja, äh ein ein, ein Scheiß. Ähm,
Genau, dafür braucht man kein Cookie, die IP würde reichen.
Geht's eben um Werbebetrug.
Das könnte sogar sein.
Weil da macht es halt Sinn, dass äh all die Cookies mitgeliefert werden und so weiter. Hat aber hier nicht gesagt, ne? Also Cyberattacke äh im Sinne von Werbebetrug. Ähm das.
Sie trotzdem anhand der IP-Adresse stellen. So und dann sollen sie mir ich würde ja also der entscheidende Punkt ist,
Mit ihren Nutzern können sie das ja machen. Die haben ja offenbar dieser dem äh Papyus des äh Zuckerbergs äh dazugestimmt. Aber ähm,
mit mit Nutzern, die äh mit denen kein äh keine Dingens haben,
die sollen dann eben bitte auch in Ruhe gelassen werden. Ich finde das eigentlich schlimm genug, ähm dass sie diese scheiß Buttons überhaupt haben, ja? Also bei den Flatterbuttons ist das ja leider ähnlich bei eigentlich all diesen Buttons. Es gibt ja diese schöne,
Ich glaube von Heise äh unter unterhaltene äh Lösung, wo du so ein Javas gebt hast, was dir die Buttons quasi,
Andeutet und wenn du einmal draufklickst, werden sie dann auch geladen und dann kannst du nochmal draufklicken und dann hast du das geliked, weil muss man ja liken oder sowas bei Facebook.
Leck mich am Arsch.
Lied, ne? Ja.
Ist ein Lied, like mich am Arsch, oder? Von Deichkind oder so, oder? Heißt das nicht, so? Ich weiß es noch nicht mal, Tim, ich bin so hinten dran, mitten.
Neu. Ähm ja.
Mit dem ganzen Cool. Ähm ja, auf jeden Fall ärgerlich und ich finde das eigentlich immer ganz, ganz schön.
Stimmt, gibt's wirklich so ein Lied von Deichkind, hast du ihn auch gar nicht.
Nein, du bist genauso cool wie die du.
Ja. Das glaubt mir jetzt zwar keiner, aber ist so naheliegend, also auf die Idee muss man einfach äh muss man einfach mal kommen.
Aber ist spannend. Also belgisches Gericht hat diesen Datenschutz sein Recht gegeben und gesagt, ihr habt achtundvierzig Stunden Frist mit dem Mist aufzuhören und ansonsten zahlt ihr zweihundertfünfzigtausend Euro am Tag. Gerne übrigens auch an dieser Stelle an mich, ja?
Aber ich glaube eher an an die belgische Kasse, die die wahrscheinlich auch grade sehr gut gebrauchen kann.
Das wäre ihr immer ganz gut, dass solche äh Vergehen dann auch irgendwie auch den entsprechenden Organisationen zugutekommt hier. Die Zeit damit vergeuden, dass die ganzen Missstände aufzudecken.
Ja. Ja.
Also wie das so bei GPL-Violations äh gelaufen ist. Da haben wir diese ganzen Strafzahlungen äh ganz ordentlich äh diverse Projekte durchfinanziert, was dann wiederum ganz hübsch ist.
Muss es laufen, ne. Also Herr Zuckerberg äh unsere Spendenkontonummer,
Seite.
Pass auf, wir machen das so. Wir wir wollen sowieso von Facebook täglich ähm,
zweihundertfünfzigtausend Euro auf das Konto des CCC, sonst äh sperren wir die Accounts. Machen wir.
Genau, da machen wir jetzt so ein Anonymus Video.
Zuckerwerk, wir machen deinen Account dicht.
Wir machen dich fertig.
Ich sehe schon, weißt du was,
was passieren wird? Weißt du, was echt passieren wird?
Morgen ist dann äh im äh ist dann ein Dedosangriff auf Logbuch Netzpolitik DE und dann sitzt irgendwo so ein Teenager im Keller und prügelt sich auf die Brust so.
Platt gemacht.
Gehackt.
Geil, echt cool.
Jetzt, jetzt geht's wieder oh. Ah ja, das wird der.
Downtime, das geht auch wieder vorbei. Einfach nicht drauf reagieren.
Gucken, wie sie mal gucken, wie viel Power die haben.
Nö, also ich weiß nicht, so eine kleine äh Erwähnung dann war heiße. Langfristig, sicherlich ganz ordentlich so.
Man muss ja nicht immer gleich Landesverräter sein, um mal groß rauszukommen.
Was auch noch äh groß rauskommen könnte.
Ähm oder was was groß rauskommen muss. Wir haben da auch schon mal dazu aufgerufen, aber ich möchte das einfach an dieser Stelle auf Wunsch unserer ähm Schweizer Freunde nochmal tun,
und daran erinnern, dass es ja in der Schweiz die Petition gegen das äh Nachrichtendienst Gesetz gibt.
Also nicht Petition, sondern äh sozusagen der Versuch, ein Referendum zu starten, ja.
Referendum, sorry, genau. Ähm ein und dafür brauchen sie ja jetzt, bis irgendwie Dezember Mitte Dezember oder so bis Dezember. Ähm,
Fünfzigtausend Unterschriften bis zum Ende des Jahres,
Man kann sich unter WWW Nachrichtendienstgesetz Punkt CH Unterschriftenbögen herunterladen, ja? Das ausdrucken und dann.
Kann man äh hoffentlich, wenn diese Unterschriften zusammenkommen, das ist eine immer ein sehr, sehr großer logistischer Aufwand, äh sowas zu schaffen. Ähm,
kann man dann eben ein Referendum gegen dieses Gesetz anstrengen. Diese Initiative des Referendums ist ein Gemeinschaftsprojekt von dem Chaos-Computer-Club Schweiz, der digitalen Gesellschaftsschweiz und der Piratenpartei Schweiz und dem,
verein Grundrechte Punkt CH, also dem.
Einer Grundrechte äh NGO, äh die sich hier in der Schweiz engagiert und,
wer also Schweizer ist oder Schweizer kennt, der ist angehalten, ähm da eben auch mal sein eigenes Engagement hier,
Kurz einzubringen. Ähm die fünf Gründe hatte ich, glaube ich, vor ein paar äh vor ein paar Sendungen auch nochmal zitiert. Es geht um die ähm,
Unverhältnismäßigkeit dieses Gesetzes, ja, sind enormen Ausbau der Kompetenzen, ähm die also Eingriffe in die Grundrechte darstellen, äh Eingriffe in Privatsphäre und freie Meinungsäußerung,
und ähm diese sind eben Rechte, die einmal durch die Schweizer Bundesverfassung und die europäischen Menschenrechtskonventionen in der Schweiz äh sichergestellt sind und ähm,
da eben wird der äh die Maßgabe der Verhältnismäßigkeit äh verletzt. Ähm,
Es ist irreführend, weil alle überwacht werden und nicht nur wenige Verdächtige, wie eben immer behauptet wird, ein ähnliches Argument, wie wir eben auch bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung immer sehen, in begründeten Einzelfällen greifen wir auf die Daten zu, aber wir überwachen erstmal einfach alle.
Es ist natürlich gefährlich, denn äh sie wollen auch in im Rahmen dieses Nachrichtengesetzes äh Staatstrojaner äh ermöglichen, also in fremde Computer eindringen. Auch da natürlich immer wieder ein,
großes Risiko, eine versteckte Hausdurchsuchung, die hier stattfindet, die wir ja auch hier schon mehrmals ähm,
behandelt haben, die grundrechtlich äußerst bedenklich ist und eben auch die Sicherheit von IT-Systemen verletzt.
Es ist,
unvereinbar, weil da bestimmte widersprüchliche Aufgaben eben beim Nachrichtendienst des Bundes zusammengefasst werden. Einerseits soll er äh zuständig sein für eigene Spionage. Anderseits für Spionageabwehr. Das ist genau
dieser ähm,
den ich ja auch immer wieder oder den der CCC immer wieder kritisiert, innerhalb des äh Innenministeriums und das Ganze ist eben auch unnötig, denn.
Satz zu sagen,
Schmerz natürlich in Zeiten wie heute, wie heutigen, aber ähm diese gesamte Überwachung hat eben offenbar äh wenig Potential äh,
der realen Welt passierende Gewalttaten äh nennenswert ähm an ihrem Geschehen zu hindern.
Also, Nachrichtendienst Punkt CH ähm unsere schweizerischen Hörer und Hörerinnen.
Dienst Gesetz Punkt CH.
Habe ich was anderes gesagt?
Dienst CH, glaube.
Oh sorry, nee.
Sein, dass da die anderen sind.
Da sitzen die anderen da. Da bitte keine. Da bitte vorsichtig mit den Referenten sein.
So, aber man soll ja der Bundesregierung nicht vorwerfen, dass sie untätig äh ist.
Ja, der hat erstmal einen IT-Gipfel gemacht. Er macht sie aber jedes Jahr, ne?
Genau, das ist wichtig, ja. Oft gab's den schon, paar Mal wahrscheinlich.
Nee Moment mal, ich bin mir gar nicht, ich glaube nicht, dass der vom von der Bundesregierung gemacht wird, wird ja nicht vom Bitcom gemacht.
Ach so, ja, kann auch sein.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh. Also, äh, jetzt sieht man wieder unsere schreckliche Ignoranz.
Zugeben, dass ich das äh am Rande mitbekommen habe.
Nationale IT-Gipfel.
Nationaler IT. Nee, ist tatsächlich vom Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft und Technologie. Und Energie.
Steht hier oben in dem Logo. Mhm.
Ja, stimmt. Energie, na ja, die da kommt ja immer irgendwas dazu, was gerade irgendwie hip ist.
Ja, da war also IT-Gipfel.
Ja, wenn wenn Blumenkohl irgendwie demnächst wichtig ist, dann steht da auch noch Blumenkohl. Das wird keiner.
Ministerium für Blumenkohl.
Na ja, muss ja auch mal an Blumenkohl denken.
Also das ist dann so, ne, da da kommen dann die ganzen Unternehmensvertreter und dann kommt da der Innenminister und der Wirtschaftsminister und dann wird hier über den Cyber gesprochen und so, das ist sicher war sehr spannend, ich war nicht da. Ähm.
Im Rahmen dessen zum Beispiel passieren so Sachen wie das dann das BSI präsentiert dann eine Studie.
Zur Unsicherheit von äh von äh Software, wo sie also sagen, schaut mal hier, wie viele Sicherheitslücken in diesen ganzen die ganzen amerikanischen ähm,
Softwarehersteller uns hier äh reinwürgen und so, ne? Aber interessant fand ich, dass,
Thomas de Maizire, sich da zur,
Kater zur Stärkung der vertrauenswürdigen Kommunikation bekannt und selbige unterzeichnet hat. Ähm,
Die wird also jetzt auch, wurde also bei dem IT-Gipfel offiziell vorgestellt und da möchte also weiterhin das Ziel verfolgen, Verschlüsselung, Standort Nummer eins auf der Welt zu werden.
Wir stärken vertrauenswürdige Kommunikation, insbesondere auch durch Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung. Ähm,
gleichzeitig hat das äh hat das Fraunhofer
Institut zusammen mit der Deutschen Telekom, die Volksverschlüsselung vorgestellt, also eine Open-Source äh Software, die
Basiert, wir erinnern die Initiativen von ähm United Internet und auch den Anbietern eben das äh Mailpile, äh Mail, The Lobe, Plugin, äh zum Einsatz zu bringen, um dort äh PGP-Verschlüssung.
Zu ermöglichen und da muss ich ja jetzt mal sagen.
DE Mail.
Aber auch in in in E-Mail made in Germany oder so, ne? Also es gibt da ähm Initiativen.
Und das ist ja nun mal auch etwas, was ich vor, das ist jetzt auch schon wieder, wie lange ist das her?
Zwei Jahre, ist jetzt zwei Jahre nur oder oder doch, in dem oder habe ich den beim, ich weiß ja oder habe ich beim neunundzwanzig C drei gehalten, äh Bullshit, made in Germany, wo ist also äh in einem Vortrag beim CCC-Kongress, wo ich halt,
das auch angefordert habe, ja, dass da die äh Regierung ähm und auch die Wirtschaft,
dafür sorgt, dass wir ähm in der Breite derartige Technologien nutzen können.
Dreißig C drei hast.
Dreißig C drei. Und insofern muss ich auch sagen, dass das generell mal zu,
befürworten ist, wann immer äh sich eine solche Initiative ergibt, insbesondere bei den bei den großen Playern.
Und auch, dass hier mit dem Fraunhofer-Institut zusammengearbeitet wurde äh und das Ganze eine Open-Source-Software ist, entspricht ja im Prinzip einfach mal alles allen Maßgaben, die man in diesem Bereich so hat.
Also, danke dafür, insbesondere, da unser Innenminister äh sich hier zur Verschlüsselung bekennt, in einer Zeit, in der eben andere äh Regierungsoberhaupt,
Häuptlinge äh ganz andere ähm Ideen vertreten, was also die Verschlüsselung angeht, ne.
Aber.
Das haben alle schon kurz aufgeatmet, aber nee.
Im
Also ich sagte, in diesem Vortrag hatte ich gleich auch so gesagt, so keine Regierung der Welt ist so blöd, ihren äh ihren Bewohnern,
ihren Bürgern ein abhörsicherlich ein ein abhörsicheres Kommunikationsmedium zur Verfügung zu stellen und so stellte.
Der Thomas de Maizire gleichzeitig äh gleichzeitig,
In den letzten Tagen eine neue Sicherheitsbehörde vor, mit deren Hilfe Internetkommunikation besser überwacht und Verschlüsselung geknackt werden soll.
Die Behörde soll unter anderem den die Aufgabe bekommen, neue Methoden zu entwickeln, um in verschlüsselte Kommunikation etwa bei Messengerdiensten eindringen zu können.
Hm.
Er sagte dann auch irgendwie in einem.
Typisch wirren, Zitat, man muss andere technische Möglichkeiten entwickeln, bevor die Verschlüsselung beginnt oder zum Entschlüsseln,
es geht nicht um einen Unterlaufen durch den Staat. Ähm,
Und er hat dann wohl auch dieses sehr schöne Zitat äh gebracht. Sicherheit durch Verschlüsselung,
und Sicherheit trotz Verschlüsselung. Das ist sehr schön, weil das äh genau diesen inhärenten Interessenskonflikt äh so schön.
Aufzeigt, der einem Bundesinnenminister und einer Behörde, die Spionage, Abwehr und Spionage in sich vereint.
Ähm.
Das ist nochmal die die Formulierung nochmal wiedergeben.
Sicherheit durch Verschlüsselung und Sicherheit trotz Verschlüsselung. Die das sind die beiden Sicherheiten, ne, also Sicherheit durch Verschlüsselung gegen andere Angreifer und Sicherheit gegen,
Kriminelle, obwohl sie verschlüsseln.
So, was meint der gute Mann? Also Konstantin von Notz hat dann eine noch schön kommentiert. Ja, das ist ja so wie vegetarisch, aber mit viel Fleisch, ne?
Aber worum's hier eigentlich geht, äh ist ganz klar, Staatstrojaner, ich höre dir trapsen. Das,
Da können wir uns jetzt schon drauf vorbereiten. Äh markiert meine Worte. Es wird nicht lange dauern, bis wir eine erneute Initiative ähm haben zum Staatstrojaner. Die muss dann.
Wahrscheinlich oder die wird dann wahrscheinlich nicht von unserem Freund Herrn de Maizire kommen, weil das betrifft ja dann eher die den Gesetzesbereich der äh,
Strafprozessordnung, also können wir damit rechnen, dass wir von unserem so lieb gewonnenen ähm Standhaften.
Kämpfer für die Freiheit. Heiko Maas.
Freiheitskämpfer Heiko Maas äh dann relativ bald eine neue Initiative zum Staatsrainer bekommen.
Genau. Wo er dann bestimmt wieder irgendeinen Tweet, den er vor zwei Jahren gemacht hat, nochmal relativieren muss,
beißt jetzt gerade keinen, den er abgesetzt hat, aber schauen mal.
Volksverschlüsselung, da weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht, ob ich mich jetzt mehr an an an linke durch linke besetzte Häuser äh erinnert fühle oder an Bild-Zeitungskampagnen.
Volksverschlüsselung. Interessanterweise schreibt Fraunhofer auf seiner Seite, dass es vor allem gegen Massenüberwachung schützen würde.
Ende zu Endeverschlüsselung schützt vor Massenüberwachung. Das soll die Telekom sozusagen mit dabei ist. Ähm dass das hier sozusagen als primäres,
ähm Nutzungsszenario eigentlich äh oder Sicherheitsszenario geschildert wird.
Spannend.
Na ja. Ist wieder eher.
Bestimmt alles ändern.
Säuft's. Kommen wir dem Ende entgegen.
Kommen wir dem Ende entgegen. Mach mal Musik.
Ja, Termine und äh wir haben schon ein paar mal darauf hingewiesen auf den zweiunddreißig C drei, den zweiunddreißigsten Chaos Communication Kongress in Hamburg und da weisen wir jetzt nochmal drauf hin, denn jetzt sind die Tickets online.
In Österreich findet am dritten Dezember zweitausendfünfzehn der erste Netz,
Abend in Wien statt, das äh aus Berlin schon so bekannte und erfolgreiche Konzepte des monatlichen netzpolitischen Abends in Berlin.
Soll hier dann auch.
Wien Anwendungen finden unter den Vortragenden befindet sich unter anderem Tom Lohninger zum Thema der Netzneutralität nach der EU-Verordn.
Meral, Alkin Hecke über digitale Medienkompetenz und Andreas Kirsch berichtet über die EU-Datenschutz-Rif.
Ja, das war's dann auch schon. Mehr Termine haben wir derzeit äh nicht zu vermelden, aber das reicht ja eigentlich auch erst mal. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, wenn's äh weitere Termine gibt, dann sind wir immer dabei.
Jetzt steht da Buchtipp.
Ja, es steht hier überhaupt erst mal Ende der Sendung sozusagen. Aber ich wollte noch einen Buchtipp äh geben,
Warst du so am Rande schon mal zitiert, aber äh,
Kauft euch doch mal äh ein Buch und zwar frisch erschienen. Die neueste Ausgabe von Asterix,
Auch Asterix und Obelix genannt, aber hier steht ja nur Astrix drauf. Äh heißt
und ist auf eine belustigen Art und Weise äh sehr aktuell. Ich weiß nicht, habt ihr vielleicht schon von gehört, da haben wir noch nicht äh mitbekommen hat. In dieser äh Ausgabe von Asterix
wird eine Geschichte äh geschildert, wie ähm der Cäsar ein äh Buch schreibt, irgendwie über seine ganzen Kriegsgeschichten
unter anderem auch ein Kapitel darin über die wirren und Schwierigkeiten des die zu besiegen unter Erwähnung des geilischen Dorfs,
Ist ihm dann irgendwie äh sein Aditant äh doch nahe legt. Diese Informationen doch nicht zu veröffentlichen, weil das käme ja nicht so gut,
Lässt sich da über äh reden und stampft das Werk ein, aber dann wird es eben von, man ahnt es schon von den, von den äh Schreibern,
entführt und sozusagen geliebt. Ja und dann gibt's irgendwie.
Äh ein blonden Kaja,
Äh Julius? Nee, Polemix heißt der.
Genau, der auf Kolportage äh unterwegs ist. Für die galische Revue und ähm der ahnt es schon, also das Ganze ist sozusagen eine eine wunderbare,
Parabel über dieses ganze Wikidix äh äh Geschehen mit ganz interessanten Internetanleihen. Unter anderem gibt's irgendwie so äh einen Kurznachrichtendienst mit Vögeln,
Das wird die grandios. Na ja, äh ich weiß noch nicht so ganz genau, äh wie ich den so einordnen soll in seiner gesamten Qualität,
ähm gegenüber den anderen äh Astrix Geschichten. Da hat jeder sicherlich so seine eigenen Favoriten, aber äh ist auf jeden Fall ein interessantes Zeitdokument. Der Papyros des Cäsar.
Danke für die Empfehlung, Tim, ich tue den mal auf meiner Amazon-Funceliste.
Oh wie lange es wohl dauern wird. Hm tja, sonst noch was?
Ja meistens sagen wir, wenn du noch irgendwas Abrundendes, um um den Mensch das Gefühl zu geben, es wäre gar nicht so schlimm.
Ja und Danksagungen gibt's auch.
Aber das würde auch jetzt an dieser Stelle nur verunsichern,
insofern. Ich möchte an dieser Stelle noch dem Christian danken und,
mich dann auch verabschieden.
Ja, ich verabschiede mich auch. Das war äh die Krisennummer von Politik. Wir sehen uns äh bald wieder. Tschüss.
Tschü.